so you're still having trouble with
battlefield 2042 huh well we're going to
talk about that and some delays
dice one of the developers behind
battlefield 2042 has added another one
of the game's issues to its growing list
of problems that it's investigating the
bug this time around is rubber banding
the enemy of many first-person shooters
which players are experiencing in the
game's main mode all-out warfare this
joins some hilarious recent bugs like
hovercraft vehicles driving up the sides
of skyscrapers according to a post on
the battlefield direct communications
twitter account any rubber banding
player's experience isn't their fault
the tweet said quote this is an issue
occurring on our side and we're all over
it if you didn't know rubber banding is
when a player snaps back in between two
positions on the map so you try to go
somewhere you come right back you try to
go somewhere you come right back so yeah
i got props to help me explain while
battlefield 2042's developers are
already fixing rubber banding it's the
latest in a long line of issues that
players have had to deal with since the
game launched in early access on the day
the game came out players by and large
were unable to actually play due to an
error message that read unable to load
persistence data
so you know how next february is super
packed with big game releases well one
of those games has decided to jump ship
and is headed to august volition's new
saints row reboot has been delayed
originally scheduled for release on
february 25th 2022 the game is now
launching six months later on august
23rd 2022 in a statement volition said
it underestimated the impact of covet 19
on the development schedule and it wants
to make sure it can bring the game up to
quality standards that the studio has
set for itself and what fans deserve
volition boss jim boone went on to say
that nothing will change for the saints
row reboot story characters or anything
else involving the core of the game now
i know they said coven 19 but come on
it's too much of a coincidence elden
ring gets pushed to february 25th and
now saints row leaves february 25th i'm
sure it had to be a tiny piece of their
decision come on i can't be the only one
that thinks this let me know in the
comments
now let's shift tones and talk about an
update on yesterday's activision
blizzard story following yesterday's
report that activision blizzard ceo
bobby kotec knew of sexual misconduct at
the company a group of shareholders have
sent a letter calling for his
resignation the group is being led by
the strategic organizing center
investment group whose executive
director told washington post quote
activision blizzard needs a new ceo
board chair brian kelly and lead
independent director roberto morgado
with the expertise skill set and
conviction to truly change the company's
culture if kotik doesn't resign and
kelly and morgado don't step down from
their positions by the end of this year
the shareholder group has threatened
that it will not vote for the
re-election of any current board members
you can head over to gamespot.com for
more information on this situation as
the updates just keep pouring in
thanks for watching hope the rest of
your wednesday is fantastic
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you